Thursday PFT ot in other words we make
Chris work a little bit longer before he
launches into his three-day weekend oh I
have a feeling you've gotten unbuttoned
coming up later today so you know I do i
rly done but we got several different
topics we want to get to things we could
not jam into the show today because
we've been limited to 90 minutes over
the past few days because of the whirl
Ascot which is fine we will always stand
down for actual sports especially in the
pandemic and it's the pandemic that
gives us our first topic on pft ot
because of the corona virus the NFL is
considering and this is according to NFL
media expanding practice squads from 12
to 16 my reaction that Chris is it makes
sense but they better be ready to do a
lot more than that
because I just think yeah extra guys on
the practice squad it's not going to
prepare you for an outbreak on your team
they better have a bunch of guys ready
somewhere and I've suggested you know
like what the XFL did they had one
entirely separate roster of players who
were practicing and ready to go in
addition to the eight teams that they
had in the league so there's 32 teams in
the NFL the math is simple for rosters
should be out there practicing ready to
go with players who are kept away from
other teams and if someone gets
coronavirus if there's an outbreak
you've got players available that you
can replace 5 10 15 20 if there is a
massive spreading of the corona virus in
any one roster yeah I mean Mike
certainly I agree with just about
everything you said and yeah it's the
first thing that crossed my mind when
they went 12 to 16 I just thought I
think you're gonna need more than that I
do you know and to this specific point
you know of course we know this can be a
highly contagious you know virus and
everything like that but so the reason I
would think you need more than 16 is you
know you've got to be careful of a whole
position group getting wiped out right
so you can't just go okay I got 16 guys
and you know one or two offensive
linemen and one or two defensive linemen
and then two or three linebackers and
then a few secondary guys and a few wide
receiver
what I'm worried about is like an
offense the offensive line for the New
York Giants they all get wiped out it's
somehow it's in their meeting room for
whatever reason and all of a sudden it's
literally like wait no four of our
starters or five of our starters can't
play what one of the New York Giants do
so to me that's where like there has to
be real depth with guys ready to go it
can't be just like oh we have one or two
guys here just in case I don't know if
one or two guys just in case is gonna
get it done if this virus does catch on
to a football team or a certain position
group like I said so those will be my
concerns I'm with you there Mike they're
gonna do their best to keep guys
separated during meetings and there's
gonna be outdoor meetings and virtual
meetings and whatnot the concern I have
is when you have a 22 man scrum on a
football field on a Sunday Thursday or
Monday and if there is one guy that
slips through the cracks positive and
that virus spreads around and of course
it's more than 22 because you've got
substitutes and backups and the punt
team and the punt return team and the
field goal team and you got all sorts of
people in that space during a game and
then you find out five days later as
both teams are getting ready for their
next game that half of the roster is
positive that's my concern what do you
do and I think back to 1987 back when
your dad was playing Chris the players
went on strike the NFL quickly put
together 28 rosters of replacement
players they need to be ready to have
guys who get injected onto these rosters
and those guys need to be ready to
because if you're a veteran who's
healthy you don't want some guy that's
just off the street that's been sitting
on his couch for the last three months
that's why I think there's an urgency to
have a pool of players who you know are
ready game ready plug and play just like
what the XFL did that's what this needs
to evolve to it's going to cost money
and that made one of the reasons why it
hasn't been mentioned yet but just
expanding a roster and and and having
four extra guys that you got to worry
about when you're trying to keep the
virus out of your locker room right do I
really want to have
four more guys and this leads to the
next point yeah right the teams are
thinking about taking fewer than ninety
to camp seventy-five or eighty because
they don't want to have all those guys
and then the question becomes who do you
cut before camp even starts you're not
cutting your draft picks you're not
cutting your starters I think the middle
class is gonna get affected here you're
gonna have guys making three four five
million a year who get their walking
papers before training camp and the
young guys have maximum opportunity to
prove themselves win those roster spots
save the team some money and save the
team the hassle of having 90 guys
floating around for four weeks well
that's certainly a real possibility now
the teams that do that though you know
the concern I would have or they think I
would challenge their to throw the
challenge Vikas yeah okay you know you
you might have saved a few million
dollars by like you said cutting some
you know proven veteran football players
man you gonna really roll the dice on
the year of Koba 19 of no OTAs and
really no young player rookie player
second-year player development getting
better anything like that
so the teams that do do that you know
that's fine but just don't expect me and
Mike to stick up for you week five when
you're oh and five and you're going well
we did this no there's no excuses we're
gonna crap all over you go now you
decided to save money and now you're
losing games and this is your issues and
we're gonna tell you why so that would
be the big thing too Mike and you know I
just want to address one other thing you
said about like signing guys off the
street you know that's real - if I was
in offense or defensive lineman you know
first off you have to worry about the
health of players - on the field still
here and if you're a right tackle and
all of a sudden you have a right guard
who hasn't played real football starting
in a game next to you and having to
block some guy like Fletcher Cox or
Aaron Donald one he's gonna be a danger
to the guys next to him he's not gonna
be in football shape he's gonna be
off-balance he's gonna get tired and
anybody that knows anything about
scouting you're building a football team
especially with those tough guys you
don't want guys that are on the ground a
lot guys that are on the ground mess up
the design of your plays they usually
fall on other players on your team
and hurt them too and that would scare
me that definitely would so that's why I
think your point of having guys that are
ready to go and in game shaped is not
only critical for the the viewer and
watching the game and the quality of it
but I think it is about protecting the
guys that are actually there playing to
that you're not next to some guy who's
just not physically ready to be out
there yeah when it was the replacements
in 1987 who cares they're all
replacement blades cannon fodder right
they're all Rudy's right now you're
gonna have Rudy lined up next to the guy
that's making 15 million dollars a year
and if that guy screws up bad enough
he's gonna get the starter injured these
are real concerns that's why I'm telling
you what they need to do is have four
separate rosters hire a retired coach or
a guy that's been fired like a huge
accident out there looking for something
to do to supervise practices keep these
guys in shape keep them healthy have
them ready so it isn't a guy that you
are basically scraping off of his couch
with a spatula and saying we need you to
play in two days which is what they this
is just the stuff they have to be ready
for they got to be ready for every
permutation it can't just be we'll see
how it goes
we'll make it up on the fly and we'll
deal with it when it comes you don't
want to cancel games you do not want to
cancel games and the best will that is
to have enough guys ready so if there is
an outbreak that wipes out 1520 guys on
the roster for two weeks you've got the
players who can walk right in the door
and not compromise the the guys who are
out there on the field gut yeah yeah
that just kind of popped into my brain
you know here's we're having this
conversation and you kind of talked
about it like yeah we can test you're
gonna have all this going on but then we
still got a 22 players scrum on a Sunday
afternoon and things can get passed
along too you know where does where does
the NFL draw the line off the field for
the players to this is something you
know in the NFL on a Friday afternoon
and you're home you're the home team man
for most players in football what does
that mean that means family members are
coming into town
to watch the game or be with the family
as they walk the game and I'm listen I
know that traveling and there might not
be fans in the stadiums but I I still
worry about hey and maybe in some states
where they're not taking the virus as
seriously as others now you got some
grandma or grandpa or your father and
dad coming into town you know hey yeah
we're not going to the game but we're
gonna watch the game here at my son's
house with his family why my son goes
play football and now you know who knows
did they bring a virus into the house
that starts to go to the team it's like
those are the things that I worry about
too and I wonder if the NFL has to like
step in line there to go hey players no
outside visitations this year whatever
it may be I'm just throwing stuff out
there that's been popping in my brain
yeah no look this hole and it's good and
again when we throw this stuff out there
we're not rooting against football
season we're not hoping there's no
football season we are trying to do our
part to to provide just our insights on
the things that they maybe need to
consider and I understand they've got
people who are hired and paid
specifically to do this but I haven't
gotten a whole lot of confidence that
and maybe they're just keeping their
plans quiet and they want to be flexible
but man I mean if anything some of the
developments in recent days make me
think that there's going to be a lot of
of let's just see how it goes and let's
hope for the best and I don't know that
that is an effective plan one of the
plans that really wasn't something that
anyone anticipated happening this year
for the NFL this movement by the various
teams to make Juneteenth June 19th the
commemoration of the freeing of the
slaves a holiday and most of the teams
have done it now the league office was
one of the first entities connected to
the NFL to do it it's the right thing to
do it's overdue but it's better late
than never the reason we mentioned it
though is Washington is doing it and Ron
Rivera communicated the decision in this
text message email whatever the specific
format was was obtained by JP Finley of
NBC Sports Washington I want to read
some of this from Ron Rivera and I want
to tell you what my theory on this is
Ron
véra communicated the decision on
Tuesday explaining that an internal town
hall discussion gave him new perspective
on many of the societal issues that have
been highlighted and learned a great
deal after hearing all your stories
experiences suggestions about how our
organization can make a difference in
helping to make our community safer for
people of color
Rivera added that the Town Hall that
they held in the organization is only
the beginning and we still want to hear
your suggestions on how we as an
organization can take action in the
fight against social injustice and
police brutality so on Friday June 19th
Rivera challenged all of the employees
of the organization to take the day to
reflect on the discussions this past
week and dive in and do some research to
come up with additional ideas additional
ideas we can implement to improve our
community now we must put our minds
together and take the next step in
creating programs to fight this battle
that's Rivera's Meadows the team Wow and
Chris there's two options here yeah
there's nothing in between either Ron
Rivera when it comes to the dictionary
defined racial slur that is the name of
the team either he is completely and
totally tone deaf or this is his way yes
of trying to build something organic
internal that takes on a life of its own
and that leads to the inescapable
conclusion Dan Schneider that the name
of the team must change
I am hoping and I am assuming that that
is who Ron Rivera is and that that is
what Ron Rivera is doing I have reason
to believe he's been made aware by
people outside the organization of the
urgency to change the name and I again
hope and assume and give him the benefit
of the doubt that he's not tone-deaf
that he is using this mechanism as a way
to begin the conversation have it bubble
all the way up to the owners office yeah
right and then doing it internally in
the organization to where they could
talk about a brainstorm come up with the
good ideas whatever it may be and then
hopefully you're right that filters the
Dan Snyder and he goes okay
yeah that makes sense and I got
supported my organization and they want
to do it all those things you know first
off I'm with you you know not that I
know Ron Rivera real well but the few
times I've been around him and he's one
of the nicer guys in football I think
he's very self-aware and aware of the
times and what's going on and sensitive
to all those issues you know without yes
maybe trying to throw his owner totally
under the bus that is the guy that
employs him and do that but I think this
was a nice political way of kind of
starting the conversation without really
starting the conversation and I think
that's very smart of him and something
needs to be done it would certainly send
a strong statement to the world to our
country to people of color everything
like that if the Washington Redskins
would would change that name you know I
think it's really cool we had two
coaches yesterday Ron Rivera and Anthony
Lin you know kind of put a stake in the
ground a little bit and I think say some
things without being too boisterous or
or making headlines but still making a
point of Colin Kaepernick and then I
think Ron Rivera is trying to say hey we
need to start brainstorming if we're
gonna talk about racial divide in our
country we got a little racial issue
with our team name right here and we
need to start fixing our own issues
before we start you know diving into the
whole society and all that daniel snyder
clings to the 2016 Washington Post poll
that found that 90% of self-identifying
Native Americans who were polled are not
offended by the name 10% are which
that's a separate issue is 10% okay I
don't think it's okay for 10% to be
offended but even then there have been
attacks on the validity of that poll the
accuracy of that poll someone who
self-identifies is Native American may
not be truly Native American may not be
truly part of a tribe or part of tribal
activities and there was a more recent
study posted by the Cao Berkeley website
and Ron Rivera went to Cal Berkeley so
it's not like he's just gonna dismiss it
that shows that the more the more
thoroughly you identify as Native
American
the more likely you are to be offended
by that term and there have been other
attacks on that Washington Post poll and
I mentioned that because I have reason
to believe that is the first thing that
is the go-to that is the knee-jerk
reaction
anytime a issue comes up well the
Washington Post poll in 2016 said 90
percent are defended so we're fine we're
fine we're good to go so I think that's
part of what Ron Rivera has to push
against and I think the wisdom if this
is what he's doing Chris the wisdom is
you know what's our knee-jerk reaction
anytime someone from outside of our
bubble at axis we hunker down don't tell
us where do we know what to do if you
can make the question come up from
within the bubble right and it's not
someone on the outside trying to tell
you how to do your business you never
once a right part of your business
telling you how to do your business
right I don't like it when people tell
us how to do our show who aren't part of
NBC if you're part of NBC that's your
job that's your business
mind your business unless you're part of
my business and I think that's what
Rivera is trying to do if he goes around
Rivera and says the employees of your
organization aren't comfortable with
this name he's provided them a platform
to come out and say they're not
comfortable with the name hopefully they
have the courage to come out and say
they're not comfortable with the name if
they truly aren't comfortable with the
name and this becomes the ammunition for
them to get to where they need to be and
when we see what's happening aunt jemima
gone uncle been gone people are
realizing I mean they're adjusting the
Virginia logo because of the the the
piece on the the handle to the sword has
accreditation to slavery I didn't even
know anybody no I didn't know about I
didn't even know was a thing right it's
like that or changing it's time for the
NFL it's too late to get ahead of it
it's time for the NFL to catch up with
everybody else and this is the way to do
it yeah I mean there's got to be another
nickname or something that we could use
that could be you know more glorifying
to Native Americans and tribal use and
whatever it is I mean can we brainstorm
and find something that works for
everybody I mean I I would like to think
we could do that and have a little bit
more of a positive connotation around
the name and all of that yes I'm with
you Mike the time has come
you know and again that's another one
where I'd like to see the NFL like Colin
Kaepernick kind of push the issue a
little bit with Washington and you know
put a little little hot poker right next
to Dan Snyder's but to get this thing
rolling it is amazing to me that that
that that word is out there in plain
sight and a dictionary defines slur and
I think the only reason it survives
number one fans somehow can
compartmentalize the two and not think
of it as a dictionary defined slur but
secondly it doesn't get used as a slur
that's what's weird about it it's a slur
that doesn't get used as a slur and I
mean I look at it this way Native
Americans have been so marginalized in
this country they don't get slurred
right yeah I mean it's they just it's
like they're not even there we had taken
the people who were here when the
Europeans colonized the United States
long before it was the United States and
they have been just kind of completely
shoved out of society so uh except for
the fact that the name of the Washington
franchise is a hiding in plain sight
racial slur and people ask me what about
Chiefs well Chiefs isn't a slur right
Chiefs is something for another day now
right the headdress and some of the
things that that misappropriate the
culture that's problematic
yelling Chiefs at the end of the
national anthem should be problematic
should be more problematic than
conscientiously kneeling during the
anthem but let's start with the slur
let's figure out where the line is after
that but wherever the line is a slur a
racial slur for the name of a team
surely is on the wrong side of the line
Chris yeah I've been saying this for
seven years
the names eventually gonna change and
maybe it'll be 50 years from now until
the name changes and then they'll argue
for 50 years that the name shouldn't
have changed but a hundred years from
now I'd like to think sooner than that
the name is going to change I'd like to
think it changes sooner than 100 days
from now but it really is a blemish on
the preeminent sports league in America
and it's amazing to me how many people
are willing to yell
shout and scream profanities at anyone
who would dare say the name should
change yeah well that's just ridiculous
and though you know those people are
just they're close-minded they're
insensitive you know they're not seeing
the bigger picture and I think Mike the
best point you make is yeah we've pushed
the Native Americans to so many little
small corners of our country that yeah
they're not a part of everyday societal
life for most of us that Americans in
fact more times and not when you meet
somebody that tells you like oh I have
four percent Native American or
something like you're like whoa really
that's that's unbelievable like you're
you're amazed by it so yeah they've been
squashed in a lot of ways here and I'm
with you
let's just keep keep fighting the good
fight maybe we can get this done and
continue the pressure on Washington and
here's the thing and I understand that
the people out there who want me to shut
up don't know me very well the one thing
you need to know is the more you try to
get me to shut up
the more inclined I'm going to be to
never shut up and I won't shut up until
the name changes and if anybody has a
problem with that it's their problem not
mine
all right one PostScript on a story that
we've been covering this week we did not
mention it in pft live today but it is
very intriguing and this is one of the
unintended consequences from Mike Gundy
of wearing the one America News t-shirt
creating an issue within his
organization and the the first
non-apology apology that he did with
Chuba Hubbard where Hubbard was the one
who apologized and Hubbard shouldn't
have apologized he had nothing to
apologize for then the second apology
which looked like a hostage video that
dusted off an incident from 1989 in
Alfred Williams who was playing for the
University of Colorado at the time Gundy
was the quarterback at Oklahoma State
colorado beat oklahoma state that day 41
to 17 and alfred Williams on KOAT radio
in Denver yesterday made it clear
doubled down on a claim that he made at
the time in 1989 after the game then
Mike Gundy was hurling racial slurs that
start with n at multiple Colorado
players Gundy denied at the time William
Williams said that he went on the the
postgame radio show with the Colorado
play-by-play guy and and said it then it
was in the paper the next day and
Williams said yesterday it was said I'm
51 years old I have no reason to lie I
didn't back down then I'm not backing
down now and every time I see Mike Gundy
I want to run through him so a lot of
passion there from Alfred Williams
now again Gundy denied it and I don't
know what he's gonna I don't know if
he's gonna have to do another hostage
video but if I'm a player on Oklahoma
State and I catch wind of this and I
already had concerns about my Gundy this
isn't gonna be gonna give me less
concerns about my gun D Chris yeah no
it's not and I mean come on for anybody
to think like Alfred Williams and make
that up come on are you insane like
that's stupid he's never made any
accusation even remotely close to that
to anybody else he played with in the
NFL anything you know there's lots of
grease he's a really great personality
fun-loving guy you know you watch old
NFL Films videos of him talking to John
Elway on the sidelines like come on
everybody like of course he said this
and yes at the end of the day Mike Gundy
can only blame themselves you know
should have stuck the football stick to
being a coach not making political you
know statements with a stupid t-shirt
and a stupid news network I don't know
other way to say it anyway and again
it's okay to have political views but
when your political views align with a
network that espouses viewpoints that
are contrary to the interests of black
Americans and the bulk of your team is
young black men that's when it becomes a
problem it's not the fact that he has a
political viewpoint it's the fact that
he's supporting a news network and he's
the one that came out and said in that
hostage video he's disgusted once he
realized the way that one America news
deals with black lives matter the
organization that that has been a huge
part of the movement that's currently
happening so you know I don't care what
your politics are but when it goes to a
fringe that undermines the interests of
the of the very people that you are
earning millions of dollars off of and
they're not getting paid that's when
they have every right to stand up and
say we've got a problem with this
he opened up Pandora's box right and she
came out and she goes oh we got a lot of
stuff in this box here well start
letting it all out and Alfred Williams
is letting it out and I think we
probably hear more stories as we go
along but yeah you know this is there's
there's no one to blame here you know
you don't I don't want to hear that like
oh here we go you know society trying to
self-correct and do all these things and
but no there's issues here we're taking
them head-on and you know because of
this and that situation yeah it's gonna
bring up and now everybody's gonna be
looking to dig and find anything on my
gundy to see or or find out if he's ever
done or said anything like this before
too so yeah he's got a big bullseye on
his back right now and it's gonna be
interesting to see if he can survive
this whole year at Oklahoma State it was
31 years ago it was right that's fair to
point out it's fast yeah it was 31 years
ago it doesn't matter says a bad word 31
years ago it was a horrible word that's
right we're down right and he wasn't 13
right right he was he was an adult when
he said it now here's what he said at
the time it's not true they were doing
the talking
why would I say those things I've been
here for years and half my friends on
the team or black it makes no sense that
was Gundy then you know will he even
address it now I don't know
and and and please let's not go oh it's
cancel culture run amok and Florio has a
vendetta against Gundy look Gundy
brought this on himself and it all began
with his team standing up and expressing
their concerns and if none of that had
happened this story that's been out
there for 31 years doesn't come back
again now Alfred Williams isn't talking
about it yesterday Shannon Sharpe
who talked about it yesterday on
undisputed isn't discussing it it was
out there it allegedly happened yes
Gundy denied it but it's it's part of
this broader narrative of whether or not
he truly has the sensitivity truly has
the sense if equality and fairness that
justifies making 5.1 million dollars
while coaching a team that is made
of a majority of young black men who
don't get paid for their efforts it's a
fair question for those players to ask
and this is fair information for them to
factor into their deliberations on
whether or not they feel comfortable
playing for my Gundy period yeah period
no there's there's a culture of that in
college football anyways it's a little
bit of like you know for lack of a
better phrase the good old boys network
where there's a lot of coaches who I
don't know they're necessarily qualified
to be leading young men and being the
face of a school or a university of
higher learning and whatever it may be
but you know they're there because you
know they were friends with the ad or
the ad and the school president or other
powers to be it would involve later if
they like drinking beer with that guy
I've had a lot of good beers with that
guy he's great I'm gonna let him coach
the team now yeah okay great great that
he's a good beer drinker he's just a
jerk of a human being other than that oh
okay no prob to leave young men there's
certainly a culture of that in college
football there's a lot of that and it
has always bothered me and I think this
is a pretty good example of it right
here and for all the issues in the NFL's
relates to the hiring of minority
coaches college football has been much
much worse over the years so just just
food for thought and continuing a story
that we weren't looking for that we
didn't start this wasn't a social media
attack on my Gundy the attack emerged
from within his very team and yes social
media was the platform but but so what
social media is just the tool for people
to express themselves it drives me crazy
how many people out there want to
dismiss social media by saying it's just
this bastion of left-wing ideas it tells
me you can experience the last three
weeks yeah I don't see all on the
left-wing I see a whole lot of attacks
on the things that we say that that skew
progressive that ultimately I don't care
about left or right I care about right
or wrong and in the aftermath of George
Floyd's murder Chris you and I have been
committed to right not wrong and it's
amazing to me that even something as
basic as right or wrong can become a
political hot potato no I'm with you
yeah
and I've never I never identified myself
as Republican or Democrat you know yeah
it's full transparency I don't look at
it like that I buy usually in my history
had voted for the person that I thought
was best for our country and the person
I liked the most I did not vote for
Donald Trump the last presidency no but
it wasn't because he was a Republican
you know I wasn't thrilled about Hillary
Clinton either I probably would have
voted for John Kasich maybe if he was
the Republican nominee I don't know
so but yes I'm about America and
treating people better making America
better making the lives of a lot of
people in this country who yes are not
as privileged as us white Americans are
and haven't been given the benefit of
the doubt with so many different things
that go on in our culture
I'm for helping trying to help those
people have more of a life that that's
better for everybody so yeah I don't get
that and I'm sick of the political stuff
yeah okay right now I've leaned left a
little bit because I don't I don't agree
with everything the president says and I
am a guy that's very much into the
environment as you know and that's just
a little opposite of what the right
things right now but it doesn't mean I'm
like I'll never vote for a Republican
ever again that's the other issue we got
to get out of this country like this is
my side and I don't ever leave it no
matter how many good facts you give me
like stop it everybody like let's get
the facts and then determine where you
are from there but right now nobody can
ever say they're wrong or readjust their
thoughts and it's troubling this entire
discussion flowed from the realization
from three and a half weeks ago that
based upon the manner in which law
enforcement officers not all but some
and too many treat black Americans it
shows that there is not a true sense of
equality and that there is systemic
racism and these are things that we are
finally dealing with that white America
isn't just saying oh that's a shame
that's horrible that shouldn't happen
and then going back into the bubble of
our day-to-day lives we are spending
time educating ourselves about the
struggles of black Americans over the
years and trust me the struggles didn't
end with slavery they just changed they
continued
in all sorts of course and fashions
strong resentment in the South in the
decades that followed because the slaves
were freed and the South lost the civil
war and I think there's still some of
the resentment down in come on States
well then people argue there's no
systemic racism I want to go wait are
you kidding me and Mike Florio's
lifetime black people weren't allowed in
certain colleges in our country how do
you think that's gonna work for the
advancement of that culture when you're
not allowed to go to some schools
because the higher learning but you
don't think there's a systemic problem
like that's insane in the membrane okay
and you're I'm starting to get pissed
off so let me I got two more things to
say I got two more things to say look
that the majority has looked down on
minorities and different ethnicities
ever since the country was founded I
live in an area where a hundred years or
so ago when the Italians were coming
over to be sent underground to work in
the coal mines or sent into steel mills
because nobody here wanted to do those
jobs so they lured the Italians and
other Europeans over there our deeds in
the county where I live that prohibit
the sale of that real estate to Italians
I mean there was open blatant
discrimination against the towns in the
area where I live and in the hundred
years since then we've taken over so
take that but Bill Russell the the great
NBA legend he had a quote earlier this
week and an item he wrote for Boston
Globe magazine and I'll leave you with
this Chris this is from Bill Russell let
me remind you of the unfulfilled promise
the one right there in the Declaration
of Independence all men are created
equal they are endowed by their creator
with certain unalienable rights that
among these are life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness I've been waiting
my whole life for America to live up to
that promise that's Bill Russell and
that says where we are and folks like
drive aside your politics and ask
yourself is there true equality in this
country look yourself in the mirror
search your heart search your mind
search your soul do some research and
ask yourself is there too
and if there isn't and you're the one of
the ones pushing against it why why are
you so all right Chris that's it for
today enjoy your weekend
happy birthday to Charlotte we'll check
out the new edition of Chris Sims on
button coming later today I'll be here
tomorrow with big cat for another
edition of PFT live all weekend long all
day long every day of the year Pro
Football Talk comm and CC everybody back
here on Friday you the man Mike SIA
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports